SO THIS IS JUST INTO CNN, A
SOURCE CONFIRMED TO N A
FEDERAL GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATING JANUARY 6TH HAS
SUBPOENAED FORMER WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL PAT CIPOLLONE.
ABC NEWS'S FIRST REPORT THAT.
CNN HAS NOW CONFIRMED THAT AS
WELL.
ABBY PHILIP, DAVID CHALIAN,
MARK PHILIP, DAVID AXELROD ARE
ALL BACK WITH ME HERE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING.
THIS IS BIG NEWS.
WHAT'S SAY YOU, DAVID CHALIAN?
>> I THINK WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS THIS
ESCALATION IN THIS GRANDEUR
PROCESS, THAT IS SEPARATE ANY
PART FROM ALL OF THE DOJ
INVESTIGATIONS AND PROSECUTIONS
INTO THOSE THAT ACTUALLY STORM
THE CAPITAL AND BROKE INTO THE
CAPITAL.
THIS IS NOW, AND HAS BEEN,
WE'VE SEEN AS PENCE AIDES HAVE
BEEN CALLED IT AND WHAT HAVE
YOU, GETTING INTO THE INNER
SANCTUM.
WE DON'T GET MORE INTERSECT AND
THEN THE WHITE HOUSE INNER
COUNCIL, WHO WE KNOW THROUGH
TESTIMONY GIVEN TO THE JANUARY
SIX COMMITTEE, WAS RUNNING DOWN
THE HALL TO THE OVAL OFFICE TO
TRY AND STOP MEETINGS FROM
PROGRESSING, WHO WAS TRYING TO
GET THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF ALIVE AND WEAK AND
ENGAGED IN WHAT WAS GOING ON ON
THE SIXTH.
SO I KNOW THAT CIPOLLONE AND
HIS TEAM ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH A WHOLE HOST OF
CONVERSATIONS AND NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE DOJ ABOUT WHEN HE CAN
AND CANNOT SAY.
BUT THIS DOJ INVESTIGATION AND
THIS SUBPOENA OF CIPOLLONE,
THIS IS A SERIOUS HEART ATTACK.
I DON'T THINK THE DOJ IS
FOOLING AROUND HERE.
AND I THINK THERE IS GOING TO
BE AN INVESTIGATION OF --
THIS >> THERE IS A NEGOTIATION
WITH THE HOUSE COMMITTEE,
BECAUSE THE HOUSES RACING A
CLOCK.
THEY NEEDED TO GET WHAT THEY
WERE GOING TO DO DONE BECAUSE
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONGRESS TURNING OVER IN
JANUARY.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL
PURSUE HIM, AND THEY ARE GOING
TO TEST THIS ISSUE OF PRIVILEGE
BECAUSE THERE IS NO PRIVILEGE
IF IT RELATES TO THE COMMISSION
OF A CRIME.
AND THEY WILL PURSUE IT IN A
WAY THAT THE HOUSE KIND OF --
>> I THINK THE QUESTION GOING
FORWARD IS WHEN THEY DO PURSUE
IT, AND IT GOES TO THE COURTS,
HOW QUICKLY DOES IT GET
RESOLVED, EVEN IF THESE FEDERAL
PROBES, AS IN THE PAST, SOME OF
THE JUDGES AND SOME COURTS HAVE
TAKING A LONG TIME TO COME DOWN
AND RULINGS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT PRIVILEGE APPLIES TO
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES, A COURT
THAT MOVES MUCH MORE QUICKLY
WILL HAVE THIS MOVING ALONG.
AND I THINK EITHER WAY, THOUGH,
IT PUTS CIPOLLONE IN A POSITION
HE WAS NOT WHAT THE JANUARY SIX
COMMITTEE.
HE WAS BASICALLY ABLE TO GO
INTO ROOM OF THE JANUARY SIX
COMMITTEE AND WAS ABLE TO SAY
HERE'S WHAT TOMORROW TO TALK
ABOUT, HERE IS WHAT I'M NOT.
AND THEY WERE AMENABLE TO THAT.
BUT IT IS NOT GOING TO BE THAT
KIND OF SITUATION WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT A FEDERAL GRAND
JURY AND YOUR TALK OF FEDERAL
CRIMES.
>> YOU GUYS ARE RIGHT, BECAUSE
AS I SAID, WHAT'S ABC NEWS'S
REPORTING, CIPOLLONE IS GOING
TO TRY NEGOTIATE THIS LIKE THEY
DID WITH THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING THE
ATTACKED.
WHICH YOU MENTIONED, THEY'RE
EXPECTED TO ENGAGE IN THESE
NEGOTIATIONS AROUND ANY
APPEARANCE WHILE WEIGHING
CONCERNS REGARDING POTENTIAL
CLAIMS OF EXECUTIVE VILLAGE.
SO YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE THAT
CHANCE.
>> FOR SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN IN
THE WEST WING, AND HAS BEEN IN
THAT SITUATION, THERE HAS TO BE
SOME KIND OF PRIVILEGE GIVEN TO
--
>> AND HE IS THE WIFE OF A
FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
>> BUT TO DAVID'S POINT, IF
THERE IS A CRIME BEING
COMMISSIONED, AND THERE IS NO
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING WITH
CIPOLLONE IS THAT HE IS NOT A
MAGA GUY, YOU KNOW, HE IS
SOMEBODY WHO, YOU KNOW, TOOK A
JOB, WENT AND DID IT.
AND HE WAS VERY OPEN WITH THE
JANUARY SIX COMMITTEE, WHICH
I'M VERY SURPRISED, HE MIGHT
NEGOTIATED IT OUT.
BUT HAVE HIM COME IN AND SAY
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT HE DID
ON VIDEOTAPE THAT WERE SHOWN,
YOU KNOW, DURING THE HEARINGS
WAS AMAZING, I THOUGHT.
A REALLY HELP MAKE THEIR CASE.
>> ALL RIGHT, SOME LEGAL
ANALYSIS NOW, ELIE HONIG JOINS
US NOW.
ELIE, WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW, PAT CIPOLLONE,
GRANDEUR ANY, FEDERAL GRANT
JOURNEY SUBPOENAED THE FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL PAT
CIPOLLONE FOR THIS
INVESTIGATION INTO JANUARY 6TH.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
>> WELL, DON, PAT CIPOLLONE IS
THE ULTIMATE INSIDER.
AND I THINK WE SAW WAS INVOLVED
IN, PRESENT FOR, WITNESS FOR SO
MANY OF THE KEY CONVERSATIONS.
AND GENERALLY SPEAKING, HIS
ROLES AS A VOICE OF REASON,
TELLING THEM NO, YOU CAN'T TAKE
OVER THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
NO, YOU CAN'T GET ON BOARD WITH
US FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME.
NO, JOHN EASTMAN'S THEORIES ARE
NOT LEGAL, THEY'RE NOT
CONSTITUTIONAL.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS HERE, AND I THINK
ABBY PHILIP WAS JUST ALLUDING
TO THIS, IS HOW HARD IS DOJ
GOING TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
THESE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
CLAIMS?
BECAUSE WE THINK TO PAT
CIPOLLONE'S VIDEOTAPE
DEPOSITION TESTIMONY, WHICH WE
SAW SOME OF THE HEARINGS, THERE
ARE THESE MOMENTS WHERE HE WAS
ASKED WHAT WAS YOUR
CONVERSATION WITH DONALD TRUMP,
PAT CIPOLLONE WOULD SORT OF
PAUSE, TURNED HIS LAWYER AGAIN
IN MICHAEL PEROT, WHO ARE USED
TO WORK FOR IDEOLOGY, AND WE
JUST SAY PRIVILEGE.
AND HE WOULD NOT ANSWER.
SO, IS THE OG WILLING TO GO TO
COURT TO FORCE HIM TO GIVE
THOSE ANSWERS?
OR ARE THEY WILLING, ARE THEY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE
SOME SORT OF POINT WHERE THEY
AGREE ON WHAT CIPOLLONE WILL
AND WON'T GIVE THEM?
IF THEY DO GO TO THE COURTS
THOUGH, A, THAT'S GONNA BE A
VERY HIGH STAKES BATTLE, AND
THE, THAT COULD TAKE QUITE A
WHILE, THAT COULD TAKE WEEKS
AND MONTHS.
>> ALI, THIS COULD ESCALATE,
THIS COULD TAKE IT TO A WHOLE
NEW LEVEL, I MEAN, YOU HAVE THE
FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL
BEING SUBPOENAED, THIS REALLY
RATCHET THINGS UP.
>> YEAH, THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT AND WHEN WE ADD THIS
ABOUT WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT WHO
THE COMMITTEE IS SPEAKING WITH,
THIS IS THE NEXT LEVEL OF FROM
MARC SHORT, GREG JACOB.
THIS IS THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL.
HE IS IN ALL THE ROOMS FOR ALL
THE BIG MEETINGS.
SO, THIS IS, YES, JUST ANOTHER
SIGN OF HOW SERIOUS AND HOW
FOCUSED DOJ'S ARE NOT JUST THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT THE INNER
SANCTUM OF THE TRUMP WHITE
CNN'S SENIOR CRIME AND JUSTICE
CORRESPONDENT KAITLAN POLANTZ IS
JOINING US NOW ON THIS.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL THAT THEY
WILL BE HEARING FROM HIM.
>> BRIANNA, IT REALLY, REALLY
IS.
AND FOR THEM TO GO AFTER PAT
CIPOLLONE TO TRY TO LOCK DOWN
WHAT HE KNEW ABOUT JANUARY 6th
JUST SHOWS HOW SERIOUS, HOW
SIGNIFICANT THIS CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION IS INTO JANUARY 6.
MY COLLEAGUE PAMELA BROWN WAS
ABLE TO CONFIRM LAST NIGHT A
STORY FIRST REPORTED BY ABC NEWS
THAT FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL
PAT CIPOLLONE HAS BEEN
SUBPOENAED BY THE FEDERAL GRAND
JURY THAT IS INVESTIGATING
JANUARY 6th OUT OF WASHINGTON,
D.C. AND THIS SORT OF
FACT-FINDING STEP, IT WOULD BE
THE SORT OF THING WHERE
PROSECUTORS WOULD WANT TO TALK
TO CIPOLLONE PROBABLY ABOUT WHAT
HE SPOKE TO THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE ABOUT, BUT ALSO WHAT
HE WAS WITNESSING, WHAT HE WAS
HEARING IN THE WEST WING, MAYBE
THINGS THAT THE HOUSE SELECT
DIDN'T ASK HIM ABOUT, OTHER
THINGS HE MAY HAVE WITNESSED.
PART OF THIS, TOO, THAT PAM HAD
LEARNED WHEN SHE WAS DOING THIS
REPORTING IS THAT CIPOLLONE AND
HIS ATTORNEYS ARE IN DISCUSSIONS
OVER ACCESS, OVER EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AND WHETHER
PROSECUTORS CAN ACTUALLY GET TO
TRUMP'S STATEMENTS THEMSELVES.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALREADY
KNOW IS A BREWING FIGHT AND A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE AT THAT
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE THE OFFICE
OF THE VICE PRESIDENT, MARC
SHORT, GREG JACOB, THEY HAVE
ALREADY BEEN INTO THE GRAND JURY
AND EVERYTHING THAT THEY SAID
THE ONLY THING THAT THEY STOPPED
AT WAS BEING ABLE TO SHARE WHAT
TRUMP HIMSELF WAS SAYING.
SO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
ABOUT TO GO AND HAVE A FIGHT
OVER POSSIBLY GETTING ACCESS TO
TRUMP'S STATEMENTS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT COULD
BUBBLE UP WITH CIPOLLONE AS
WELL.
AND IF WE REMEMBER BACK AT THAT
HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING
WHAT WE'VE HEARD OF CIPOLLONE
SAYING BEFORE IS THAT THE KEY
THING HE HAD SAID WAS THAT TRUMP
WAS THE ONLY PERSON IN THE WHITE
HOUSE WHO DIDN'T WANT TO TELL
RIOTERS TO LEAVE THE CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6th.
THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE MADE
A VERY BIG DEAL ABOUT THIS, BUT
EVEN WHEN CIPOLLONE WAS
TESTIFYING TO THAT AT THE HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE HE WAS VERY
HESITANT TO SAY EXACTLY WHAT
TRUMP SAID AND EVEN TO NAME
TRUMP IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
BECAUSE HE KEPT CITING EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
SO THIS COULD BE SOMETHING THAT
BRINGS US TO ANOTHER COURT
FIGHT, BUT IT REALLY IS AN
AGGRESSIVE STEP BY INVESTIGATORS
TO WANT TO BRING HIM INTO THE
GRAND JURY AND LOCK DOWN HIS
TESTIMONY.
>> IT WAS CLEAR THAT UNBURDENED
BY WHAT HE PERCEIVED WAS THAT
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE HE WOULD
HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT SO HE WILL
HAVE A LOT TO SAY THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE GREAT
REPORTING.